Hello Psych2go-ers
We just wanna take the time to thank you for all your time and support
We are a team of dedicated, hard-working and passionate individuals
who come together every day with one goal in mind:
We wanna make psychology come ALIVE for you
We are self funded and recently launched our Patreon
If you enjoy the work we do and find it meaningful,
PLS stick around to the end of this video
for information on how to get more involved with us
and all the cool rewards you can get from us.
We hope you enjoy this video~
Dating can be a *delicate* dance
One wrong move, and your partner can swing away from you
This is why relationships aren't fairytales
and require a large degree of work to sustain them.
When you're with the right person,
they're *always* worth it though.
But no matter how much we want to love our partners better
We may not always understand where to start.
Highly Sensitive People, for instance-
face many challenges in the realm of dating.
Because their partners don't always know how to approach them
Whether you've been dating your HSP for a while now,
OR you're just getting started,
Here are five tip for dating a highly sensitive person.
Number One:
Don't pressure or make them feel rushed
HSP prefer to think things through carefully,
before making a decision.
Instead of quickly jumping into a situation,
they would rather analyze and observe on the sidelines
before making a commitment.
This is why they don't like to feel pressured or rushed.
They care a lot about how their actions affect others.
Which is what makes them such great and loyal partners
Once they've chosen to commit to you,
they take your relationship seriously.
Number Two:
Respect their need for space & time to be alone
If your partner needs to recharge
try not to take it personally.
They aren't doing it to ignore you,
but because it helps them function as a person.
RESPECT your partner's need for space.
In fact, the only way your partner to be at their best
is when they aren't overwhelmed or over-stimulated.
If you'd like to understand your partner's habits more,
check out our video, 8 Signs You're a HSP
Number Three:
Understand that conflict makes them uncomfortable.
Disagreements are normal in relationships,
Because you and your partner are welcome to have different opinions,
but when your partner is highly sensitive,
it's important to be mindful of how conflict makes them feel.
HSP *dont* enjoy fighting
because they find it distressing and overly stimulating.
To reduce conflict, try not to fight
You don't have to act like robots or
pretend everything is fine when you experience problems,
but emotions often distract us from resolving them.
One way to minimize fighting is to
give each other signals or warnings
*before* things get out of hand.
Number Four:
When doing activies together,
choose less stimulating environments.
HSP don't like being in loud, overcrowded places.
They may go to parties to catch up with friends,
or be supportive of weddings and birthdays,
but they prefer to leave early,
when they start to feel drained.
To reduce your partner's stress,
bring them to peaceful environments like-
the beach when it isn't crowded,
a hike in the woods,
or a quiet coffee shop.
Number Five:
Reach out frequently
and ASK them how they're doing.
According to Elaine Aron,
researcher of highly sensitive people,
she discovered a trait they all have that she refers to as
Mate Sensitivity.
Mate sensitivity is the ability to understand what pleases your partner.
HSP are *great* at knowing what to say and do
to make their partner feel loved and appreciated.
But it's important to be receptive
and return the same gestures of love
Be considerate,
and make sure your partners needs are being met too.
Are you dating a highly sensitive person?
Do you find these tips helpful?
Please, share your thoughts with us below!
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from Psych2Go
AND check out our Patreon~
With your contribution, you can receive
our PSI(?) Pendant, T-shirt, Issues of our MAGAZINE
AND many more membership benefits.
We wanna make sure our community members get the best and only the best
Thanks for watching!